I would say that the hedge fund people
make a lot of money in their favor
little tax I'm about the middle class I
want the middle class to be thriving
again we're losing our middle class so
change the tax code I would change it I
would simplify it I would put in this
respect you want to tax carried interest
in the same way as ordinary income his
tax I would take carried interest out
and I would let people that are making
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
pay some tax because right now they're
paying very little tax and I think it's
outrageous
I want to lower taxes for the middle
class I want to lower taxes for people
that are making a lot of money that need
incentives so that would so that would
affect not just hedge fund people that
would also affect people in limited real
estate partnerships which you were in a
fair number I'm okay so your proposed
you're proposing that you'd like to
raise taxes on yourself just instance
I'm okay with okay you know ready
willing and you see my statements I mean
I do very well I don't mind paying some
tax the middle class is getting
clobbered in this country you know the
middle class built this country not the
hedge fund guys but I know people in
hedge funds they pay almost nothing and
it's ridiculous okay